so how did you get approached to be on
Celebrity Big Brother you know 20 21
years ago so when the show started I
heard on TV someone on the TiVo
something about a houseguest that I
thought they're talking about me yeah
and I ran in the room it was a
houseguest show yeah brother so from
that moment on I said I'm the guy for
this show okay meant to be the
houseguest yeah and so that's how it'll
happen
CBS contacted me and they're like we
need the og houseguest in to be in the
house so they put me in the house are
you nervous
being confined with all these
celebrities you know nervous about I'm
nervous that I mean addicted to my cell
phone
social media and it's become a confided
organ in my body so it's like losing my
liver by the way I'm a 42 regular if you
have one you know but I have so I'm
thinking to myself oh can I can I do it
yes so far I've been sequestered three
days it's so difficult I'm making it but
it's straight cold turkey yeah I think
that's gonna be the most difficult part
otherwise I think with people I'm gonna
be okay this is the hard part when
you're separated now but when you get in
the house you're gonna have friends
friends I don't know enemies I think
what could happen is they I'm gonna be
judged the most I think people have
formed an opinion yes can I already know
that I want people to know that I know
the reason I'm there there was a
horrific tragedy two young people that
lost their lives and from that I know
that I can't change the past
yeah and everything I do from my moment
on has always been to pay it forward and
I always live a very positive yeah so
everything about now is it's like to the
light and I'm really really appreciative
of CBS for the chance to show me a
chance that people know who I am
there's gonna be negative people no
matter what you do but like it wasn't
like you were then gonna go work at
Barnes & Noble like you had to choose to
continue what you were already doing
before this happened which was the
entertainment business so I'm happy that
you're getting this opportunity it's a
great thing I just think great things
will happen because of it I kind of work
to get to work and I do a show know the
last three years called Wizard World and
I I'm with comic-con the world's largest
travel show I'm an entertainment stage
I've been all over America we got the
rights to Asia my life has changed from
these three years ago I do press in
every single city Wow and I see the
reaction of how it was from 20 years ago
ten years ago to now and
a reinvention blessed yes things are
bright who would you hate to be stuck at
a house with and who is your dream
celebrity Alliance who I'd be hate to be
stuck in the house guest is probably a
criminal you like I've been there I have
for sure that I've learned from my past
and who I'd love to be sucking on but
someone that can have that the bromance
with how do you want a bromance bromance
where I can actually have probably 11 of
them okay my goal is that everyone that
I meet in the celebrity houseguests I
become friends with even after it's a B
okay well you're gonna hate some of the
people I'm just letting you know
that's how Big Brother works some people
are gonna annoy you some people are
gonna not like you but I appreciate that
on day one you are so positive can I
tell you something that you're wrong on
yeah I don't have hate don't hate
congratulate um but if they're evicted I
will not mind it at all yeah exactly to
get to the end you got to be a little
bit savage yeah and I think you're gonna
have to hate congratulate savage kick
you out Buster but in a physical
challenge okay I can read that
you know biggest fear biggest fear is
probably with the cell phone with my
favorite thing having to do with that is
I don't have to read evil tweets you and
me both yeah I don't need to you the
meanest thing I couldn't stand in there
it's it's has to do obviously with the
OJ trial and you know words like scum
and much much yeah you know adjectives
in front of that it's just and these
people who don't know these beat up how
competitive are you I'm born to win
really you seems way too nice to be born
to win there's been some people in here
that I know are born to win you seem
like you're born to hug and I still
don't believe you at all are you really
there to where are you competitive
competitive I was raised in Wisconsin I
was raised all sports my entire life was
high school sports sports sports in
trying to win I'm better person winning
I can make people happier than if I lose
when i lose i'm ugly i hate me as a
loser and when my team's look i just
don't like me when i'm a loser okay now
most people in this series that are
regular bigbrother they just go back to
their lives you've never had in this
normal life so what are you hoping this
exposure from this
massive I mean the following on the show
is insane does for you well I think work
begets work yeah I already have a job
and employed with this wonder wizard
world and I travel year-round and then
we started Asia
so I'm complacent there I love it so
much
but I really think opportunities will
happen yes I just feel this many things
just already happening before this a few
stars on the first Celebrity Big Brother
for various reasons decide it's too much
for them and sent themselves home is
there any possibility you would quit
well I saw the last Celebrity Big
Brother the first one and the good news
is I'm not lactating yes true and that
means I'll stay mm-hmm and I saw a lot
of Tears a lot of Tears I'm not gonna
cry I don't think you're definitely
gonna cry
I'm already know but you're everyone
cries on Big Brother I'm not gonna cry I
feel myself a won't cry I mean the first
person to cry no we're gonna replay this
on a loop when you cry on episode 1 I'm
gonna cry in your interview I know did
you reach out to anyone from season 1 to
get advice or if you should do it no I
did go to a taping of the finale and I
could only stay for a little bit cuz I
was working it yeah when I was there for
that I was sat next to a Moroso and I
saw her style of play tough she's a
tough kid is gonna make you cry I think
the people that know the game yes I
think now it's a disadvantage I'm going
in there I know how I know the game and
I get it but I think you've you're a
Loki you're under the radar yeah you
wait until the first week is over
mhm then you make your move it's an
interesting thing today I've been
meeting all of you Big Brother
houseguests because every single one of
you has said I'm just gonna lay low I'm
gonna lay under the radar mine I'm glad
you told me that little tip yeah here we
go
ok so food situation can be tough are
you a cook I'm not a cook food is the
least thing you worry about I don't even
care if I even eat or not I would like
to be roommates with Gandhi that's that
okay I don't care you a cleaner
what is your use gonna be in the house
you're not looking for us my therapy is
laundry
I love folding my own laundry it gives
me my it's proud of my mom and I love
doing laundry do you know that sometimes
you have to eat swap if you lose this
often yeah I understand you ready for
the swap you don't care yeah yeah thank
you no I know to vomit yeah you're fine
what is your strategy for winning big
brother
I think the strategy is not for me at
the strategy is for the other houseguest
I got to get it on their side I got to
make them feel you know what a person is
really loving yeah and what person that
kinda makes you laugh I think that's a
hard person to get rid of yes and I
think I'm that guy what are you gonna do
with $250,000 probably invested yeah
yeah some people said they buy a car
other people said they took family on a
trip I have a girlfriend and she's from
Beijing I think I do want to go to Asia
I would do the Asia trip and just go
bake good okay maybe not the cloud hotel
yeah but I'll go Marriott Mary you are
incredible
Wow yes but you're also I was rooting
for you Toria Slee known for being I
mean the most famous houseguest of all
time now you're going to be trapped in a
house with 11 celebrities do you feel
prepared yeah I suppose I can be I think
the I think one of the hard parts is not
sleeping yeah and my whole my whole
being is if I'm arrested I'm more high
energy yeah more positive but not
sleeping which i think is gonna be
trouble
yeah is going to be very tough for me to
win because my body doesn't regulate I
need healthy energy I need to store it
up so that is my biggest fear besides
the no texting no cell phone physical is
going to be a big part of it is hard for
me because I really I didn't know if you
had it in you but throughout this
interview yeah you could take it there's
a thing yeah based on who we've seen
what I did you're kidding me
another calls coming in I did with who
is this it's gonna be amazing it is
gonna be it's gonna be amazing okay I
hope you know the I'm honored and
blessed I'm so happy that I've given
this opportunity I really mean it and I
really want just it's gonna be great
people to see me okay
don't screw it up hop on the catering
tent
she's on
see the dining cart I love it I love it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]